Okay, our first question is coming from Cammy.
What is your question to Damona?
I'm 45, I am single and I am so old-school,
where I am not approaching any man.
I can be in a party and we will just have a staring match
and then we both go home.
What advice or what tips can you give me, Damona
on how to break out of that shell and just go for it?
How, how, how?
Cammy, you're an old-school girl
living in a new-school world.
Okay?
(audience laughing)
So, I want to just set aside those beliefs
that were probably passed down to you
from generation to generation.
"This is how it's done."
We're in a complete different paradigm.
And just starting a conversation with someone,
that is not a marriage, that is not a marriage proposal,
that is not a commitment.
That's just a conversation
and you never know where it's going to go.
So, I really want you to reframe any thinking
around it being a rejection.
So I actually, I would give you a little assignment.
Okay.
To be a little bit brave.
And the next time you're making eyes at someone,
go ahead and initiate the conversation and see what happens.
'Cause the more you do that, Cammy,
the less weight you'll put on each individual interaction
and the less anxiety and worry that will come up
when you go to talk to someone the next time.
Practice makes perfect, right?
Exactly. You got it.
Let me get my practice.
Thank you. Thank you.
(audience applauding)
I agree.
I agree with that a lot.
Also, I really am having like a kind of, "Ah-ha" moment,
because I am Josie Grossie
and I think that everybody can feel that.
So when I go up to talk to a guy,
here's what's happening on the inside.
(Drew exclaims loudly) Hi.
(audience laughing)
But I think all they see is, "Hey, what's going on?"
But they can't tell what is happening on the inside.
But we think it's all out there.
And he's Josie Grossie on the inside too.
That's the crazy thing.
Is he really?
Yeah.
I mean like, Joseph Grossie.
(laughs loudly)
Joseph Grossie!
Oh, my gosh!
Damona, I am looking for my Joseph Grossie.
He's out there.
(both laughing)
(audience laughing)
(audience applauding)
Okay, our next question is coming from Linda.
Linda, what is your question for Damona?
Hi, Drew. Hi, Damona.
I need help.
Okay.
I've been on and off dating apps for the past two years.
I'm middle-aged and I would like to settle down.
The last date that I went on,
the guy showed up looking 25 years older
than his profile picture.
He lied about his profession.
He said he was a doctor
and he showed up with a stethoscope in his pocket.
(audience laughs softly)
And he lived in his office.
So my question is, how do I get better
at pre-screening and screening,
so I don't get catfished again?
I love this question.
Well, first of all, Linda, it's not in your head.
There's two categories of catfish.
There are the people
who aren't really confident in who they are,
which is what you were dealing with.
And the people who are, have nefarious intentions.
Who, you know, want to scam you and take your money.
So, I guess the positive side is that
we didn't have that kind of catfish,
but the negative side is it's just as, it's disappointing.
You've invested time and you had, you know, a hope
that this person was going to be who they said they were.
So, here's what I want you to look out for next time.
On the photos they have to be,
they have to seem current.
If they're not crisp digital quality...
Like, we're all carrying high-quality cameras
in our pockets every day.
There is no excuse for having like, a scanned photo
or something that looks like it's too far away
or isn't really clear.
And you can always ask for more photos
if you're not really sure.
Also in those photos, if they look posed,
and I'm not talking about like, posed.
I'm talking about like, brochure level posed.
(Drew laughs)
That is a really big sign.
And especially if they're in a uniform.
Like, you'll see this a lot of times with doctors,
with people in the armed services.
So, look out for those things.
If you're spidey senses go off and you feel like,
"Oh, I don't know about this picture",
go and run it through a Google image search.
Do you know how to do this?
Yup.
Just in Google, you can go into the search bar.
You can go up to image and you can search a photo
and see if it comes up associated with anything else.
Anything that doesn't match with what they've told you.
That's how I found out he wasn't a doctor.
Well, there you go.
So you wanna do that before you get invested
and before you actually meet up with this person.
Another sign is that they'll love bomb you.
They'll tell you all of the things that you wanna hear.
They'll whisper sweet nothings into your inbox.
And then they,
if you step back and you read what they've said,
you realize it could kind of be said to anybody.
It might not be that specific.
That could be a sign of the other kind of catfish.
Also, if those people don't want to meet up in person
or won't at least do a video date.
Now, that is a primary screening to get to the date,
to do a video chat date.
And if they seem squirrelly about that
there's definitely something going on.
Linda, what do you think?
Definitely helpful.
I don't know why I didn't think of it myself.
Yeah.
Exactly.
(audience applauding)
And you are so stunning.
Thank you.
Like, you are the catch and I can see this about you.
And it's funny, when it comes to ourselves
all of a sudden we don't have that same sort of
fierce loyalty of protection.
So, you are so worth it.
You are so beautiful inside and out and you are not alone.
I swear I've gone through the same exact things.
Just elusiveness, too much mystery,
I don't know where I stand,
I don't know who I'm dealing with.
I totally have dealt with the same thing on dating apps.
So, let's try and figure this out.
(audience applauding)
'Cause it's not changing.
(upbeat music)